no, we're not 100% satisfied, it's
certain that there have been measures
taken, it's always better than nothing,
but hey, we're not going to give up
like that, we're still here
mobilized for a little while well we have
been mobilized since Monday there are
others it's been longer
but we still have a lot of
work on the farms so there with
everything that has been said uh it's  that's why
for the moment we're letting go we're going
home uh I'm still a little on
the fence uh uh so a little a little sad
all the same uh
and there we go with still big
expectations for the weeks or months to
come  to be sure that these are
not empty promises and uh and that
everything that has been said
uh since uh TR speech in fact
since last Friday in the south
Monday at the Palais Bourbon and then yesterday
is
really applied and that that
really brings something concrete to our home we are
afgelenar in Nederland actions gevd en
daarbij zijn de Belgen onsen attenden
nu zijn de Belgen a hetesteren zijn uit
solidariteit eh ook naar de Belg gekomen
om deze te helpen met een protest en eh
ja ook names Nederland dan voor de
regering toch even een hand op te steken
van ja jongens wij zijn er ook nog eh
jullie zijn wel aan het ver nieabinet
ook